and i did love seeing you guys hit the
gym together while you were
filming usually i'm infamously known not
to invite anybody into that jesus
i didn't know i didn't know it was like
a cathedral like
no one gets to go in there so what's the
deal with this too
is this a new nickname been around now
for three years
i used to enjoy calling him very sort of
sweet
cute things like he he'd text going all
right i'm leaving now i'll see you on
set and i was like okay cupcake you know
and then
no no no no cupcake i am
yes cupcake ladies and gentlemen the
moment you've all been waiting for
the backside of water
steve's wonder of the world and welcome
to the jungle welcome
to jungle cruise i love akilah our boat
behind you it's very cool
seeing her again i know is it bringing
back memories some flashbacks
i can only imagine the film turned out
beautifully
it was so much fun uh you two are
bringing this iconic disney ride
to life on the big screen are you kids
giving you any brownie points are you
scoring any cool points with them are
they like ah i'm in phase it's
actually it's actually the only they've
only seen the trailer so far but my kids
have watched it
so many times it's been one of the only
things i've done where they're like
interested hmm what about you dj my kids
do
same thing uh a five-year-old and a
three-year-old they love
the trailer they can't wait to see it
yeah because i you know it's it the
trailer
has all those moments in it that
obviously are attractive to kids and the
families as well and also has some
really cool stuff in it as well because
i wonder if they'll
like aquaman more still why did you
bring that up because they're obsessed
with jason momoa as am i
i saw what aquaman just did
who's cool daddy
aquaman
i know they're also obsessed with wonder
woman yeah
can you blame him right
um the friendly feud you all have going
on
is next level special that's great
it's so great though from d23 to the
dueling trailers
i am so sorry about earlier something
very weird happened um it was like this
rogue trailer this this uh this
desperate delusional sad trailer air
that bears no relation to the film that
we made
who started this little feud we got
going on right here
probably didn't happen quite naturally
and then people were like that's funny
so
yeah i mean when we first met the very
first time we met
uh we instantly clicked and because you
never know
right how it's gonna be when you meet
somebody you know you're familiar with
their work
and um i had seen all of emily's movies
she had watched none of mine
so now it worked out perfectly
when we got together we instantly knew
we had something
and plus i feel like you're kind of
playing off your characters too because
you very much so have that banter back
and forth
i mean that that was the key and i think
the characters are so
it's such a cool dynamic to watch
because they're so
polarized from each other they have such
different philosophies on life and
their senses of humor like how they walk
into every day like it's just completely
the antithesis of one another
i don't got it no no no no no no no just
leave me alone that was a disaster it
didn't go the way i planned
so i think it makes for this really fun
interplay between them that's
it it is reminiscent of those romancing
the stone films where it's that
clash of like two people with her doubt
like kind of storming into each other's
world
yeah is it hard for you guys to sit next
to each other today for a chat
i thought so emily my heart goes out too
yeah
this one doesn't use deodorant so you
can imagine that wow
kidding that's the headline arms down
get one of the flowers i'm kidding don't
i always smell nice you do
you both do actually thank you yes you
both do
now or you're right yes by the way it's
warm
say one lovely thing about each other
what do you love about you go first yeah
you got to make up for that
she is one of the most sweet smelling
sweet smelling human beings i have
ever met by the way honestly we had the
best time
on jungle cruise so you know the things
that she was talking about earlier about
us being polar opposites and coming
together
our characters and having different
philosophies you throw all that together
mixed in with the adventure of a
lifetime and going down to amazon with
curses and legends and things like that
keep it about me
it is about you that's right that's
right so emily is acting
one of the greatest actors of our time i
always like to say that she is
she truly truly got it out jokes aside
yeah she absolutely is so what an
honor and pleasure it is for me to you
know work with this one i say that all
the time
yeah you have any good words that you
would like i have so many good words now
truly truly i do i
i think i think it is rare that you take
someone away from a movie that becomes a
genuine sort of like friend for life and
he has because he is my most enormous
buddy
and will always be my most enormous i'm
pretty sure he was just should you don't
do it no
those days are done all right you like
that you're giving the people
well by the way i was about to say how
wise and refined
now i love this banter the chemistry is
there the chemistry was there there's a
hint of the romance in the film between
these two very romantic
it truly is so i mean might we see that
romance play out in the sequel
and there's gonna be a secret i hope
there will be i mean it would be
wonderful if if there was and i think
there's one hopefully there we go
yeah absolutely i mean it's what we're
talking about now but you never want to
get too far ahead of yourself it always
depends on what the audience does and
how they react but fingers crossed and
early indications for audiences that
have seen the movie already
in our testings they love it they've
been going crazy so we'll see
and then the sequel will cast somebody
else fair enough
did john come to set and did he say okay
enough there dj hands off the wifey over
there
john is so sort of used to me working
with other men that it's like it's sort
of like white noise now he's like
who are you making out with who you are
it's like
it's sort of like nothing at this point
just the rock and i did love seeing you
guys hit the gym together while you were
filming the cast that trains together
stays together let's get it totally
198. 199.
ah 200. ooh looking shaky yes did
em ever hear give you any pointers about
getting shredded dj
no well she got she's been shredded in
some of her movies in the past
right so when she and usually i'm
infamously known not to invite anybody
into the nigerians
i didn't know it was like a cathedral
like it's sacred no one gets to go in
there and she just yeah just kind of
says hey can i come by your gym i'm like
sure
you can can you imagine if you'd said no
i would have been so
i said no in my mind i said but then i
outwardly said sure
so she comes over and i always know when
emily's been to the gym because
there's baby weights thrown around she
doesn't pick up and i
keep the gym very close so tidy like
he's such a germophobe he's
incredibly tidy like slightly anally
tidier
but it's a gym by the way there's sweat
and there's iron laying around but i do
like to keep it clean that's important i
don't know this one comes over she
doesn't wipe it down there's sweat
everywhere
there's baby weight imprint this is too
good not to do a sequel
i know right thank you guys so much for
letting us hang today and i hope i get
to see a quiet place part three honey
there's one coming i just someone else
is helming it the third one
all right all right john needs any ideas
tell him to give me a holiday i'll be
starring
killing her off in the movie
you